We know that if you're caught up in one
of these little world games that you may
be motivated by something very,
very fundamental,
right,
a tendency that transcends you,
the tendency to propagate yourself,
say Freud's fundamental motivational level
sexual affiliation or the tendency to
maintain yourself.
Those you could say are the
fundamental gods of existence,
the fundamental driving force.
And it's there.
It's the interaction of those two
forces over great periods of time that
produced the great diversity of life
and human life that we see before us.
And each of those fundamental,
most fundamental of gods have their
differentiated many and so to speak.
So that well engaged in the Matt
had goal of self preservation.
You Act out plots of hunger and plots of
thirst and he moved from cold to hot or
from hot to cold depending
on your particular,
uh,
on the particular temperature of your
surroundings or with regards to self
propagation.
You're attracted to people who are
repelled by them for reasons that are
frequently absolutely
beyond your comprehension,
by the way.
So I just found out this week,
and this is absolutely staggering.
I think that if you,
uh,
if you run an experiment on a group of
women and you track their menstrual cycle
and then you give them t shirts
that men have worn to smell,
that women who are ovulating like the
smell of symmetrical men better than
asymmetrical man.
So,
and that's partly because symmetrical
men are probably more healthy,
but this is a good example of how the
motive forces that configure your world
are dependent on instinctual forces that
are not only beyond your consciousness,
but they're beyond even at the moment
any of our explicit explanations.
So,
uh,
another finding that's very similar
that I came across recently,
it turns out that mice will not mate
with mice that have rh blood factors that
are likely to produce,
um,
unfit offspring.
Uh,
the more closely genetically
related the RH factors,
the more likely there is to be a,
uh,
a catastrophe with regards to offspring.
And the mice seem to detect
the RH factor by smells.
So recently this was run by with women
and it is also the case that women prefer
man who's rh factors are at
an optimal distance from them.
In terms of smell.
So this is some example of how
these unbelievably archaic systems,
cause like the olfactory systems
are unbelievably archaic,
produce alterations in Worldview
at a level that's massively below
consciousness.
So underneath your cortical shell,
which is tonically inhibiting all your
emotional and motivational systems,
lies all these motivational and emotional
systems and they have branches that
grow up into the cortex and they have
the capacity to control your behavior
completely involuntary.
So for example,
if you're gripped by fear,
it's very,
very difficult to
overcome that voluntarily.
And at least initially
you won't be able to,
which is to say that
when the chips are down,
the underlying motivational and
emotional systems have control.
Okay,
so then what happens from that perspective
then what happens when you encounter
something you don't understand?
And I think the best way to explain
it is something like generalized
disinhibition,
which is that all your
underlying motivational and
emotional systems are more or
less disinhibited simile.
Tanium.
And the reason for that is because you
want to be maximally prepared to do
whatever the hell is necessary to do
when you're somewhere that you don't
understand.
And because you don't know
what that thing is going to be,
all your systems go on.
And when psychologists talk about stress,
which is an abysmal word,
right?
It means everything and nothing.
When psychologists talk about stress,
what they mean is
generalized disinhibition.